das ist so mit allen du musst so vieles bei
der Sprache auch es wird so babylonisch alles
dauernd ändert sich was nur da haben wir auch so
vieles lernen müssen in diesem Jahr 100 Milliarden
Schulden für die Bundeswehr also sind gar
keine Schulden das ist ein Sondervermögen
sollen wir uns alle daran erinnern wenn wir
wieder auf die Bank müssen und zum Schalter
falls es dort noch einen gibt zitiere oder
ist ganz schön ausgereizt Ihr Konto ist Knie
tief im Minus hat mein Sondervermögen ja die
EZB hat doch kriege ich da jetzt auch Zinsen
Ringtausch da haben wir noch bis zu
diesem Jahr nicht an Panzer gedacht
romantisches haben alle da und dauern musst du dir
Gedanken darüber noch mal Gedanken und noch mal
Gedanken oder denkt sich ich muss nochmal raus
mal weg den Kopf durchlüften Urlaub machen und
das war in diesem Jahr toll weil die war endlich
mal wieder ohne Corona konnten wir richtig Urlaub
ich habe ganz kleinen angefangen verlängertes
Wochenende und wollten verlängertes Wochenende
nach Berlin es wurde dann ein sehr verlängertes
Wochenende leider nicht in Berlin sondern auf
dem Weg dorthin zwar blöderweise das Wochenende
mit diesem Sabotageakt bei der Bahn also zwei
für die Infrastruktur notwendige lichtwellenkabel
haben sie durchtrennt vermutlich einmal der Russe
Stunden später also eigentlich gefühlt
Tage später als ich in Berlin war habe
ich an dem Fernsehen gesehen wie diese
überlebensnotwendige Infrastruktur auf
zwei schäbigen Rangierbahnhöfen
im Ruhrgebiet und in Berlin offen
zugänglich für alle brachler sind
da brauchst du doch keinen Russen
da hätten Marder gereicht also
das Tier nicht der Panzer der
wäre nicht hinbekommen also
oder vielleicht ein paar
Pilzsammler die gesagt in Pokémon
Sabotage gegen die Band ist an die Bahn doch gar
nicht nötig Sabotage von außen das schaffen sie
doch von ganz alleine aber Urlaub war toll also
wenn man weg kam das war auch nicht so einfach
mit dem Flughäfen der Urlaub ist wirklich
weg von allem von dem ganzen politischen
Irrsinn wobei bei mir muss ich mir sagen war
so immer wenn ich weg war was daheim irgendwas
Neuwahlen politische Beben Rücktritte ich war
einmal in Cornwall also in den pilcherland und
kaum dort war hier was los hat er muss wieder
Zeitung holen bin ich zusammen zeitungskios
habe wo finde ich denn ausländische Zeitung
sagt hey ich vermute mal im Ausland das war
ich liebe den britischen Humor und und dieses
Jahr war ich auch also auf dem Weg nach Kanada
war ich auch in England und da war dort was los
vor Ort Boris Johnson tritt zurück der brexit
sauber verzockte bitte weil weiter die Tage
später kam dann auch die die neue Tendenz die
Mehrheit der Briten will zurück in die EU also
das finde ich toll also für mich wäre das ein
eleganter Tausch wir nehmen die Briten wieder
auf dafür schmeißen wir die Ungarn raus damit
der Orban mal in aller Ruhe drüber
nachdenken kann welche Werte er
eigentlich mit uns zu teilen gedenkt
und wir denken oft an Piroschka aber
wenn die Briten aber schon wenn die jetzt
zurückkämmen in die EU dann hätten wir immer
noch die also wir haben ja erst also dann hätten
wir wieder die Tories bei uns die ihr Land in
Grund und Boden gewirtschaftet haben und damit
hätten wir einen fail state eine Abrissbirne
im europäischen Haus die sinkende Insel da
kein Wunder dass da in diesem Jahr die Queen
ging schnell mit der lisbett oder also ich habe
das auch schon überrascht überraschend also zwei
Tage vor ihrem Ableben also da war sie noch
so gut drauf na auf ihrem Schloss empfangen
hat Boris Johnson um ihn aus seinem Amt zu
entlassen da hatte sie noch gefreuth endlich
endlich kann ich den rausschmeißen der aus
meinem Vereinigten Königreich sitzen gemacht
hat dann war er weggenommen
und dann wurde klar oh shit
ich muss ja seinen Nachfolgerin mit
den Regierungsgeschäften beauftragen
und da hat sie sich wohl gedacht oh nein
und dann
dann war sie weg die andere war auch also die
Trust 45 Tagen schneller als ein Salatkopf
Welpen kann aber die Taktzahl die Schlagzahl der
Rücktritte muss auch so bleiben weil wenn König
Charles III ähnlich viele Premierminister
ernennen möchte wie seine Mutter in ihren
70er dann ist es anders nicht zu schaffen schön
war dann die Ernennung des neuen premiers also
richtig zu nackt ne dem marktradikalen Goldman
Sachs noch als der von Charles seinen Diener
gemacht ich bin der Nachfolger von Liss
hat Charles nur ganz trocken gemeint und
dann hast jetzt kloppen sich die Tories schon
wieder wie die Blöden es kommt davon wenn man
die Regie ineinander Street Monty Piepen überlässt
bei uns haben viele gucken nach England so schlimm
ist es bei uns noch nicht sollte stimmt also
so ein Chaos wie mit den Tories bräuchten wir
nicht auch noch aber so ein Hauch von Monty
pyth bei uns im Kanzleramt im Parlament es
wird nicht schlecht da werden wir Stimmung
in der Bude na wenn der Minister für silly
walks einschreitet um dem Staatssekretär
für blöde Antworten Einhalt zu gebieten
bei uns im Kino die lange Nacht mit Monty Python
und bei den Rittern der Kokosnuss hat mir die
eine Stelle besonders gut gefallen die drei
Fragen zur Überquerung der Brücke des Todes
haben und musste drei Fragen beantworten
wenn ich richtig ging es nicht über die
Brücke sondern in den Abgrund habe ich mir
das Wetter immer was bei uns beim Wahlsonntag
Stimme abgeben darf also muss man drei Fragen zum
Allgemeinwissen richtig beantworten sonst wird
mir zwar nicht in den Abgrund aber damit einem
der Zugang zur Urne verwehrt und nein es gibt
auch keinen Telefonjoker ich habe das vom Kino so
vor mich hingekrabbelt war richtig richtig Laune
gehabt und da kam einer an hat gemeint ich
hätte da auch mal ein paar Fragen an Sie und
ich war immer noch bei der Kokosnuss ich war ein
entspannter dann können Sie mir vielleicht sagen
warum mit jeder Krise ob jetzt Corona oder der
Krieg die Reichen immer reiche und die Armen immer
ärmer werden also so ganz verstehe
ich das auch nicht aber ich dürfte
eigentlich gar nicht so sein
nach der Pferdeäpfel Theorie
der trickle down Effekt sagt man doch immer
gibt den Reichen mehr dann haben auch die
armen man muss nur dran glauben also glauben sie
glauben sie dran und vertrauen Sie der Politik
auf die Hand die uns füttert ist immer Verlass
ja das denkt sich die ganz kurz vor Weihnachten
dann
und dann pickt und rupft sie doch immer nur
auf der schwächere Gänschen rum anstatt mal
den zu zwicken der ja an der klare will warum
ist es so warum trete bei uns alle immer nur
nach unten wenn du die neueste Umfrage siehst da
stehen schon wieder die ganz vorne die uns den
ganzen Schlamassel eingebrockt haben warum sie
sich so viele Kälber immer wieder ihre Schlacht
des Helme warum ist das sie sind doch immer
so sie tun doch immer so als müsste sie alles
mit dem Löffel das ist was sie dafür hätte sie
doch mal intelligente Antwort ja intelligente
Antwort ja klar ähm um mit Shakes Hamlet zu
sprechen darf sie dir sagt 5 Szene Vers 28
nein
ach so also dann also dann meine sie dann weg
2023 mindestens wieder genauso schlecht wie
2022 ja womöglich vielleicht sogar noch
schlechter aber nein komm lassen sie uns
optimistisch bleiben positiv denken 2023
wird auf jeden Fall viel besser als 2024
ach so gut
ja und selbst wenn nicht machen
wir das Beste draus vielen Dank